[Music]
the average American will move eleven
point three times over the course of
their life there are many different
reasons finding a better home getting a
cheaper home getting a new job getting
married going to college getting evicted
whether it's a happy reason or a bummer
I don't know anyone who actually enjoys
the process of moving the planning to
packing the cleaning the expense but
we've got your back no we can't actually
help you load the truck sorry but we do
have nine hacks to help you save money
on your move you may have to break your
back but you can avoid breaking the bank
[Music]
look around your house how many
individual things do you think are in it
if it's the average American household
that number is 300,000 the idea of
transporting 300,000 items from one
location to another is daunting and the
more you have to move the more expensive
it will be so let's get that number down
shall we
when you're a month or two out make a
list of all the rooms in your house and
focus on one per week your job is to
pick up every item in that room and ask
yourself if you really still like it
this is not the time to be precious and
helga we'll never find out if you got
rid of her lamp you can sell the
unwanted items online or just donate
them to a local charity as long as it's
not broken or filthy goodwill will take
just about anything
for a lot of different reasons summer is
the most popular time to move more than
30 million Americans move during this
summer and another 30 million are
traveling for vacation which means the
highways are packed and so our movers
schedules if you can wait until the fall
or early winter they can save you money
movers are less busy so they will
sometimes lower their rates by up to 30%
and less traffic on the roads means more
efficient travel times and if you're
loading the truck yourself wouldn't you
rather do it when it's not a hundred
degrees if you're a renter there are a
variety of reasons that a landlord can
refuse to give you your security deposit
back
so reread your lease terms to make sure
you're in compliance getting a check for
a couple thousand dollars can be a huge
help and offsetting your moving costs
you can hire movers to do everything
pack load drive unload unpack but it
gets expensive an inner city move of a
two-bedroom apartment will cost us about
two grand here in Austin Texas
maybe that's why only 21 percent of
people use professionals from start to
finish instead if you pack your own
things right your own van and drive it
yourself
suddenly you're only paying five hundred
bucks for the load in and load out which
let's be honest is no one's favorite
part of the job one out of ten moves are
for work and if that includes you you
should definitely inquire about a reloj
package as part of your contract 39% of
all moving shipments are actually paid
for by corporations and unlike salary
it's a one-time expense that often comes
from a different part of the company's
budget so they might be more open to it
than you think
remember if you don't ask the answer is
always no why spend money on packing
material when you already have closets
of soft stuff in hand wrap your dishes
and other breakables enclose towels and
linens to protect them
cut down on waste sure it's a little
heavier than styrofoam or bubble wrap
but you're bringing this stuff along
anyway as my uncle Olaf used to say only
a sucker pays for cardboard boxes okay I
don't actually have an Olaf but
seriously there are so many places to
get them for free on Craigslist Facebook
next-door freecycle or drop by your
local grocery or liquor stores they may
be happy to let you take them off their
hands and yes I have personally pulled
boxes out of recycling dumpsters behind
a hardware store it's actually pretty
common for people to leave the fridge
and pantry to the last minute and then
decide they'd rather throw everything
away then worry about perishables going
down this is such a waste of food
especially considering it could cost
hundreds to restock a pantry from
scratch so in the weeks before your move
commit to consuming as much as you can
from what you already have the things
you can't eat will probably fit into one
or two plastic tubs that you can
transport yourself honestly a bottle of
olive oil can cost 20 bucks that maybe
is coming with me this is probably the
most important money saving tip we can
give you want to sell your furniture
instead of giving it away that takes
time want to find free boxes instead of
buying them that takes time want to
properly clean your apartment so you can
get your security deposit back that
takes time moving always takes longer
than you think and the more rest you are
the more it'll cost you so kick off your
moving plan at least two months in
advance of your last day in your old
home it will also make the experience
safer and more pleasant oh and
chiropractors are expensive so lift with
your legs not with your back and that's
our two cents
you